l'administration a décidé le
non-renouvellement noté de séjour vous
avez un mois pour quitter le territoire
français
tu as l'impression d'arriver ici on peut
pas tomber plus bas
le problème c'est que venait pas
inscrite à mon cours je viens de nuit
pas à bon attendez moi dehors on va
essayer de sauver votre peau n'en valait
pas la france alors pourquoi si je
connais la france confort coeur bon
allez casse toi plus tard reste pas là
désarmé cependant ces efforts
c'est quoi une aventure c'est plus qu'un
coup ces mots qu'une histoire rouge
alors alors prochaines élections c'est
le pen qui passe à cause de tes
conneries il passera toujours dans
les champions
car de ses joueurs je fais encore de
jouer la victime a pour petit émigrés
pasteur à [ __ ] je m'occupe à longueur
de journée de gens qui veulent pas
retourner dans leur pays et beaucoup
estiment que pour vous ce parement le
plus dramatique si c'est dramatique si
je vais pas rentrer mois
et pas de leur dire je pensais qu'on
était libre en france